why wasn't Disney's wish the kind that
comes true let's just say there are a
few reasons simply put the house of
mouse can't seem to catch a break in
2023 oh come on what is wrong with me
today the Ariana deos and Chris Pine
lead flick was released on November 22nd
boasting a budget of around $200 million
unfortunately it missed the mark
domestically only managing to capture
around $30 million over the long holiday
weekend meanwhile the film's glow
success also looks to be faltering with
its current and total box office
projections sitting just under $50
million while these numbers aren't the
worst Disney has seen in recent months
they're still an unwelcome site
especially considering the company used
to knock it out to the park with their
November releases Once Upon a Time in
2017 Coco captured over $800 million
worldwide while equipped with a similar
budget as wish and the year after that
Ralph breaks the internet naed over $500
million against since its $175 million
budget there's still time for wish to
possibly develop some legs and inch
closer toward profit territory however
these initial reports aren't exactly
inspiring so what's caused Disney's
latest animated adventure to flounder
the 2023 sag Astra strike which began on
July 14th came to an end on November 9th
just 2 weeks before wish was set to
release this meant that the film's cast
can not putze a film drawing a good
chunk of its promotional window in the
age of social media where big name
celebrities boast millions of followers
wish lust out on months of easy
advertising due to its actors being
unable to consistently hype the film
while the film's xegs definitely tried
to capitalize on the conclusion of the
SAG after strike by pushing Chris Pine
out for a few interviews before the
movie's release this was likely too
little too late to develop a strong
awareness for the animated musical
desperate times caller Desperate
Measures beyond the problem of stilted
marketing wish was not met with positive
reviews upon its release especially from
critics while audiences applauded the
film on Rotten Tomatoes critics gave
wish a rotten score at the time of this
video the movie is sitting at 50% over
on IMDb which currently has a 5.9
meanwhile many prominent Publications
and sites have reacted scathingly toward
the film for instance vulture wrote that
Disney's latest animated Adventure fails
on every level the guardian agreed and
blasted the film as a quote Disney
marketing exercise disguise as a fairy
tale meanwhile lopa own Audrey Fox gave
the film a four out of 10 citing that
the movie's soundtrack was hit or miss
and noted that it plot struggled greatly
with trying to coherently combine modern
and traditional storytelling Fox wrote
which tries to split the difference
between classic and modern and fails on
both fronts how much better would the
film have done if they really committed
to the Vintage Vibe the world may never
know this isn't Disney's first fun ball
in 2023 you may recall that many of the
company's hottest liveaction properties
have also failed to make a worthwhile
Financial Splash at the beginning of the
year Antman and the WASP Quantum Mania
released to mediocre reviews and greatly
underperformed at the box office
especially for a Marvel movie
holy that guy looks like
broccoli during the summer Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny became a
dramatic box office bomb after raking in
less than $400 million against its
whopping $300 million budget currently
another MCU Fe at the Marvels is also
drowning at the box office overall this
type of track record is not one that
inspires fans to spend their holidays
and weekends traveling to the theater to
watch a Disney flick the reasons for the
film's poor performance don't end there
upon its release wish was immediately in
competition with some other Heavy
Hitters Napoleon which stars Oscar
winner wackin Phoenix was released on
the same day as wish I found the crown
of France in the
gutter and place it at top my own head
granted an R-rated historical epic about
France's greatest conqueror isn't
exactly in the same category as a
familyfriendly animated Magical Musical
but it still crowds the box office
especially when it boasts big names like
Phoenix and legendary director Ridley
Scott more importantly wish came out
while the Hunger Games a ballad of song
birds and snakes continues to make noise
with a budget of $100 million the film
is already close to scoring double that
and its run is not even close to being
over not all hope is l for wish despite
all that's been said so far remember how
things went for Disney's summer feature
Elemental while it struggled greatly in
its opening debut it went on to net
almost $500 million at the bux office
against a hefty budget of $200 million
so there's still a chance for wish to
make something big happen down the
financial stretch however as things
stand it seems the Disney musical has
too many concrete variables stacked
against
it